الصور هي صور لعمليه اخلاء مصابين
فلسطينيين بعد اقتحام الجيش الاسرائيلي
للبلده القديمه في نابلس اذا هذه الصور
متداوله لعمليه اخلاء مصابين فلسطينيين
اصيبوا طبعا برصاص الجيش الاسرائيلي داخل
البلده القديمه في نابلس مراسل العربيه
قبل قليل الزميل عبد الحفيظ جعوان كان قد
افاد بارتفاع عدد القتلى برصاص القوات
الاسرائيليه في نابلس الى خمسه فلسطينيين
وفقا للصحه الفلسطينيه وبان هناك 45 اصابه
بالرصاص من بينها طبعا هذه الصور التي
نتابعها الان ومحاوله انقاذ احد المصابين
الفلسطيني برصاص القوات الاسرائيليه في
البلده القديمه بنابلس تحدث زميل عبد
الحفيظ جعوان كذلك عن عاشر اصابات حرجه
بين طبعا الفلسطينيين الذين اصيبوا جراء
الجراء طبعا هذه العمليه عمليه اقتحام
الاسرائيليه في البلده القديمه في نابلس
هذه صور ايضا كذلك ربما للانسحاب انسحاب
الجيش الاسرائيلي من هذه المنطقه من
البلده القديمه كما ذكر قبل قليل ايضا
مراسل العربيه هناك الهلال الاحمر
الفلسطيني ذكر بانه استقبل خمسه واربعين
اصابه بالرصاص بينهم طبعا بينهم عشر
اصابات اصابات حرجه وكذلك ايضا اصوات
اطلاق الرصاص كنا قد تبعنا معكم في بدايه
هذه النشره والتي كانت يعني بشكل
مستمر في البلده القديمه في نابلس وهذه
ربما ايضا صور من الاشتباكات بين
قوات
القوات الاسرائيليه كذلك ايضا وبين
فلسطينيين محاوله ايضا لانقاذ ما يمكن
انقاذه بعد اصابه طبعا كما ذكرنا 250 فلس
هذه العمليه